I've worked with this really great
powerlifting coach for the last couple
months it's been great my programming's
been more dialed in I had somebody who
can pay attention to the little mistakes
I'm making that I would otherwise
Overlook and I've made progress and
that's been nice after training for a
decade now what I've realized is that
the biggest thing is just get in the gym
and don't miss reps you know like put
your reps in if you do that then the
actual program that you're on it might
help you a little bit in the short run
but if you just put your reps in and
don't miss workouts and you do that for
10 years or 15 years or 20 years how far
would you get as long as you're doing a
reasonable program probably pretty far
even if you're doing don't the best
coach probably get 95% of your potential
out I think a lot of times like people
want to get in shape and they're like
what knee sleeves do I need what's the
best protein powder and it's like dude
just don't miss workouts for 2 years and
then get back to me I mean that's the
thing that that makes 98% of the
difference is are you putting your reps
in hey S car Michael and I make these
videos because I need them for me
because I want to wake up every day and
watch a video that puts me in a mindset
to believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only James Clear
enjoy decide the type of person you want
to be and then you prove it to yourself
with small wins and the more small wins
the more small habits that
you perform the more votes that you cast
for that identity the more you build up
evidence of being that kind of person
and eventually you start to take pride
in that aspect of your identity and man
once we start to take pride in a part of
our story like it's much easier to stick
with those habits if you take pride in
the size of your biceps you'll like
never skip arm day at the gym you know
or if you take pride in how your hair
looks you have this like long hair care
routine all these Hair Care habits and
you do them every day whatever aspect of
your identity that you're trying to
reinforce that's kind of the the story
you can also phrase it as a question so
for example rather than saying I'm the
type of person who doesn't miss workouts
you could have this question that's
related to the identity you want to
build and you kind of carry it around
with you all day and like in this
example maybe the question is what would
a healthy person do and so you're just
kind of walking around all day asking
yourself you know what should I get for
lunch well what would a healthy person
do or should I take the Uber or should I
walk to the next meeting well what would
a healthy person do and you just kind of
like go around your day and try to make
decisions that you feel like support
that identity but I think you start with
who is the type of person I wish to
become so let's say I'm the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts and
then the second step is prove it to
yourself with small wins so which small
actions what little habits cast votes
for being the kind of person who doesn't
miss workouts well maybe one thing
is rather than doing a 45-minute workout
when I only have 10 minutes I reduce the
scope and stick to the schedule and I do
a couple Sprints or I do you know five
sets of push-ups or or whatever it is
and so you find ways to reinforce your
desired identity even if it's small
especially in the beginning because if
you can show up consistently if you kind
of Master the art of showing up and
Performing these small habits you build
up this sense of momentum you kind of
start to reinforce and shape that new
identity and the more evidence that you
have for it at some point you kind of
cross this invisible threshold where
you're like oh I guess I am that kind of
person you know like if you go out and
shoot a basketball for 5 minutes you
don't think oh I'm a basketball player
but if you do it every day for 6 months
or a year or two years like at some
point you cross this invisible line
you're like you know I guess playing
basketball is kind of part of who I am
so I think you're trying to
accumulate actions that support your
desired identity your concept of getting
1% better is much more believable for
most people and so just address that for
a second why why 1% better every day and
how does a habit do that sure so first
of all I think there's no reason that
you can't be really ambitious right like
I consider myself to be very ambitious
person I think it's just that you're
oscillating or switching between these
two modes you know like when you're in
planning mode when you're in strategy
mode sure you can be very ambitious um
and be very um aggressive and uh you
know stretching yourself and reaching
but when it comes time to take action
and executes uh you have to scale it
down to something that you can achieve
that day you know like the in in sense
the biggest unit of time you could ever
do something is about a single day
because then you got to go to sleep you
know and then you have to wake up again
and do it the next day so unless you're
playing you know at some point there's a
limit you can only stay up for 48 hours
or 72 hours like you know and then you
break so that's the largest possible
unit that you could ever do a single
thing in and I think more realistically
most of the time the truth is you know
you got about an hour maybe you got two
hours to work on this and then you got
to go move on to something else so we
don't have big chunks chunks of time
available to us we need to scale things
down into pieces that we can actually
work on and execute so the way that I
think about it is when making plans
think big when making progress think
small and getting 1% better each day is
a way to encourage that Excellence a lot
of the time maybe we can even say most
of the time is not actually about
radical change it's about a commitment
to acre small improvements day in and
day out secondly and I think this is
also crucial it encourages you to focus
on trajectory rather than position
right there's a lot of discussion about
position in life how much money is in
the bank account what is the number on
the scale what is the current stock
price what are the quarterly earnings
there's all this measurement around our
current position but what getting 1%
better each day encourages is to focus
on your trajectory instead am I getting
better is the arrow pointed up and to
the right or have we flatlined am I
getting 1% better or 1% worse because if
you're on a good trajectory all you need
is time right if you have good habits
time becomes your ally you just need to
let time work for you but if you have
bad habits time becomes your enemy and
every day that clicks by you kind of dig
the hole a little bit deeper and so it's
very much at the core it's about
encouraging you to focus on trajectory
rather than position one of the phrases
I use I have this in the book is that
habits are the compound interest of
self-improvement so it's like the same
way that compound interest you know acrs
through Finance your the effects of your
habits multiply over time and so often
these choices that you make they're
these little 1% improvements for you or
against you each day and they're easy to
overlook on a daily basis right like
what what really is the difference
between eating a burger and fries or a
salad and chicken for lunch you don't
see a a lot better yeah right yeah it
tastes aming moment that's actually a
crucial Point uh that I covered in the
book which is that habits that are
immediately satisfying are more likely
to be repeated and so pretty much any
Behavior produces multiple outcomes
across time right like if you eat a dut
right now it's tasty and sugary but in
the long run you gain weight and so the
the immediate outcome is favorable the
long-term outcome is unfavorable with
good habits it's often the revers right
like you go to the gym right now and it
takes effort you sweat you have to work
hard sacrifice your time for Netflix and
chill to go train the immediate outcome
is unfavorable but the ultimate outcome
you're in shape and you know a year or a
month or whatever is favorable and so
the challenge for building good habits
and Breaking Bad Ones is often finding
way to pull the long-term consequences
of your bad habits into the immediate
moment so you feel a little bit of the
pain right now and want to avoid it and
the long-term rewards of your good
habits into the immediate moment so that
you have a reason to repeat it again in
the future each Behavior cast a vote for
the type of person that you want to
become and if you cast enough votes for
that type of identity you start to
believe that about yourself right like
if you you go to church for 20 years you
believe that you're religious you study
Spanish every Tuesday for 30 minutes you
believe that you are studious um so in
that way your habits provide evidence of
your desired identity and I think that
that is probably the ultimate reason
reason that habits are so important it's
true like habits can help you earn more
money or be more productive or lose
weight um and all that stuff is great
but in addition to the external results
that habits provide they also shape your
sense of self they like are the the
engine or the Avenue through which you
learn to believe things about yourself
like sometimes people will say stuff
like fake it till you make it but fake
it till you make it is asking yourself
to believe something without evidence
for it and you can do that for a little
while you could do it for a day or weak
but eventually I mean there's a word for
beliefs that don't have evidence behind
them it's delusion right and if you're
deluding yourself then eventually you
give up on that but the power of doing a
better habit each day or casting a
little vote for that type of person is
that now you have evidence to root your
belief in done six months yeah right
like I mean now you have a lot of
evidence that you're a podcaster or a
good interviewer you know like you do
this over and over again each time you
cast a vote for believing that about
yourself and you don't just you aren't
delusionally believing that you're a
good interviewer it's because you've
shown up and done it hundreds of times
right um and so I think that that's true
for any habit large or small that they
provide evidence of the desired Identity
or the the type of person that you are
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there how do you remove ambiguity from
your will to keep that Clarity of
intention and purpose behind what you do
I don't know that I have a good answer
to how to live a life with Clarity but
some of the things that I try to do
include not doing too many things so if
you're optimizing for too many things at
once is very hard to remain clear you
just have too many you got too many um
you know irons in the fire there's too
much going on um and so that is easy to
do when you're choosing between a good
use of time and a bad use of time it
becomes harder to do and I think this it
becomes increasingly true as you get
deeper and deeper into your career it
becomes harder to do when you're
choosing between good uses of time and
great uses of time um in a sense the
most dangerous things on your to-do list
the things that are most likely to
remove Clarity and cause confusion and
introduce a sense of overwhelm are items
like three through five on your priority
list because you have a good story for
why you're doing those things that's why
they're on the list to begin with and
smart people are so good at coming up
with like valid excuses or developing
stories that sound really uh reasonable
so you'll look at that list and you'll
be like oh well I I need to do this like
this is number three you know like I I
have it on the list for a reason this is
a good way to spend time I'll be
productive but the truth is items three
through five are actually the greatest
distraction to doing items one and two
because you can convince yourself that
you're being productive while still
avoiding the highest leverage work so
not taking on too many projects I think
is uh a really crucial part of it
obviously there's sort of a Connecting
Point there like a pre-step which is you
need to know what you're optimizing for
you need to know what what is the most
important thing and that requires a
little bit of self-reflection if you
take a bad habit or an unhealthy habit
like uh eating a donut or something um
the immediate outcome is favorable it's
sugary it's tasty it's enjoyable in the
moment that's how it serves you that's
the reason why you repeat it the
ultimate outcome if you repeat that
every day for the next 3 months or year
or whatever is you end up gaining weight
or you're less healthy or so on for good
habits it's often the reverse right like
sometimes uh you know the benefit of
going to the gym in many people's eyes
is the immediate outcome is unfavorable
sweat I have to work it's effortful it's
hard I need to sacrifice I don't get to
watch TV I got to go there instead um so
the immediate outcome is unfavorable the
ultimate outcome if you repeat that
habit for two months or a year or
whatever is you're fit and healthy and
this is one of the key challenges of
building good habits and Breaking Bad
Ones is figuring out ways to take the
long-term consequences of your good
habits or of your bad habits and pull
them into the present moment so you feel
a little bit of the pain right now so it
serves you less and to take the
long-term rewards of your good habits
and pull those into the present moment
so it feels good this is one reason why
you know it's great to choose like
what's the best form of exercise well
maybe it's the best the one that you
enjoy because if it feels good in the
moment now it serves you and you have a
reason to repeat it your brain is always
developing habits so it's it's happening
whether you want it to happen or not and
the question is can you take control of
the process and uh in a lot of ways the
fact that we have these mindless
automatic behaviors it's a pretty good
system that Evolution has designed I
mean if you think about it from a very
high level you're through as you go
throughout life you are facing problems
and some of those problems are big
problems and some of them are really
small ones like you need to tie your
shoe and your brain whenever you come
across a solution to the problem that
you're facing and you repeat it again
and again your brain starts to automate
that so you know you tie your shoe once
and it the first time it takes some
effort and then and so on but then you
do it 50 or 100 or 200 times and pretty
soon you can tie your shoes while having
a conversation or thinking about
something else or whatever and this is
sort of the role that habits play in our
lives is that they are these mental
shortcuts these kind of automatic
scripts that you can just play whenever
the situation or or the context is right
and they free up cognitive resources to
focus your attention elsewhere and so
that's a really good system uh overall
it's we use it all day long without
thinking about it but occasionally it
can serve us poorly because you know so
let's uh let's say you come home from
work and you feel stressed and exhausted
and that's a problem that needs to have
some kind of solution so for one person
maybe they learn that uh if I play video
games for an hour I'm no longer stressed
and exhausted for another person maybe
learn if I smoke a cigarette I reduce
stress for a third person maybe it's
meditating for 10 minutes for a fourth
person maybe they run for a half hour
and the point here is that different
solutions can cause can solve the same
recurring problems throughout life and
so your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal habit for
solving whatever the situations are that
you come across in your life the
problems that you face day in and day
out and so if you can it becomes more
about designing a better solution uh to
those to those problems and that's
really that's where my focus is is like
all right we're building habits anyway
how can we develop better solutions to
the recurring problems in our life you
can find examples of people who flip a
switch and transform their lives or have
an epiphany and do it overnight but I
think that it's rare um I think that the
more sustainable strategy the more
reliable strategy is to scale it down to
the first two minutes focus on that
establish it Master the art of showing
up and then go from there so really you
should like usually when people think
about building better habits they
optimize for the Finish Line right it's
like how much weight do I need to lose
how much money do I need to make um you
know how when can I finish this book
it's all focused on the result but I
think instead if you optimize for the
starting line make it as easy as
possible to start scale it down uh
organize your environment so all that
stuff is set up this is another strategy
for making it easy which is that you can
prime your environment to make the
future action easier right like if you
chop up a bunch of veget vegetables and
fruit on Sunday it's now easier to have
a healthy snack during the week if you
set your workout clothes out the night
before it's now easier to get into the
workout the next day but doing all that
stuff to make it easy to show up that is
probably the more important piece early
on the process of change usually starts
with self-awareness um now you can
change without being aware of it but
you're not usually in control um it
means that the environment shifted or
the circumstance or situation changed
and you changed in response but you
weren't really influencing it in a
meaningful way so starts with self-a
awareness then the next step which you
already mentioned is kind of we could
call it different things call it
deliberate practice call it routine or
you know whatever but you're consciously
doing the behavior so you're putting in
effort to practice it is there do the
stop you there is there any tricks you
know that you have found as far as that
part of it you know cuz people don't get
started they have to high of goals I've
heard a ton of different ones but could
you share with us you know some tips on
that part of it so I think there are a
couple maybe two let's pick two
strategies that you could use right away
so the first one is a lot of people feel
like they lack motivation when what they
really lack is Clarity um and what I
mean by that is they think I need more
willpower I need more motivation I need
more persistence I need more drive and
certainly those are all important
qualities in life but the truth is they
uh we often make statements about how we
want to change in very vague ways we say
something like this time it'll be
different I'll just eat better I'm going
to try harder uh whatever
and instead if we have Clarity and you
could use uh there are two strategies in
the book that I talk about for this one
is implementation intentions so it is a
intention to implement a particular
Behavior so the simplest way to do this
is you fill out a sentence that says
exactly when and where the behavior will
occur so I will go to the gym on Monday
at 5:00 p.m. at this address or I will
Journal at this coffee shop at you know
6: a.m. blah blah blah and the more
clear that plan is the more likely you
are to follow follow through and there's
a bunch of research studies that show
that people are more likely to get their
flu shot quit smoking recycle exercise
basically any kind of habit you can
think of I divide a habit into four
different stages um and so just from a
high level those stages are Q craving
response and reward so the queue is
something that gets your attention like
you see a plate of cookies on the
counter that's a visual queue or the
ambulance comes behind you on the street
and you hear it and so you pull to the
side of the road like that's an auditory
queue or your phone buzzes your pocket
that's like a physical or tactile cue um
and so it can be any of the the senses
but uh usually it tends to be visual
humans are very visual creatures so that
uh that tends to be the most predominant
sense but the Q gets your attention the
second step is the craving which is
dependent on how you interpret the Quee
so it uh you whether you get a craving
or the motivation to act uh whether you
predict that it would be useful to take
a response depends on the meaning that
you assign to the queue so if you have
two people who walk into a living room
and they see a pack of cigarettes
sitting on the table the first person
might uh they've been a smoker for 10
years and they see it and they get this
craving of oh I want to pick a cigarette
up and smoke so they interpret that
visual queue is favorable the second
person has never smoked a day in their
life and so they see the cigarettes and
they just think oh it's just a pack of
cigarettes and they move on um and so
it's really about the meaning that you
assign to that visual queue that
determines whether you act on it or not
then there's the response and finally
there would the response is the actual
habit or action itself and then finally
there's the reward or the outcome so
visual cue you see a plate of cookies on
the counter craving you interpret them
as favorable you predict oh that'll be
sweet sugary tasty so you response grab
one take a bite and then finally the
reward and the reward serves two
purposes the first is it satisfies the
craving that came before the action so
you predicted did that the TA the cookie
would be tasty and sweet and once you
take a bite it is in fact sugary tasty
sweet so that resolves that craving and
then the second thing that it does is it
teaches your brain what to repeat for
next time because when actions are
followed by a feeling of pleasure when
it's enjoyable or you got uh you solved
the problem you were facing or you had
some kind of successful feeling at the
end of The Habit it feels good and your
brain's like hey that was enjoyable I
should do this again next time when I'm
in a similar circumstance sance and so
it's actually uh closing the feedback
loop and training your brain what to do
again and again and once you've done
something enough times and gotten the
outcome that you hoped uh from it again
and again and again the feedback loop
gets really tight and you can do it
pretty much on autopilot you don't even
really think about it you're just sort
of automatically whenever you put a shoe
on and see a shoe untied on your foot
that's the cue and you know oh I just go
ahead and tie the shoe and that's how I
get this um uh reward that I'm looking
for of having a shoe securely on my foot
and so on if you want to break a bad
habit there are kind of three potential
paths you could take so the first is you
can eliminated it entirely so
elimination second option is you can
reduce it so you could like curtail it
to the desired degree I don't want to
never drink caffeine I just want to
drink less of it and the third option is
you could substitute it you could
replace it with a different habit and of
those three often times replacing it is
actually the more effective option so
for example if you get your caffeine
from drinking Coke or soda or something
like that then maybe you find out hey
you know something I really love from
this experience is I actually just like
drinking a carbonated beverage and so
it's the carbonation that I like and
maybe if I substitute it with sparkling
water or something like that I still get
the carbonation sensation but I don't
have the caffeine associated with it
anymore and so that's a way of
substituting for that behavior and you
still get something that the experience
provides this is actually kind of an
important just like larger picture big
picture thing about habits which is
every habit that you have we build
habits to solve the repeated problems
that we face in life and I'm using
problems in a very general sense here
you know like let's say that you come
home from work and you feel tired and
exhausted from a long day well in a
sense coming home from work at 6:00 p.m.
and feeling tired is a problem and
especially If you experience it
repeatedly you got to come up with some
kind of solution for that and generally
speaking we just kind of like try things
out in life and so you can imagine one
person solves the problem of feeling
exhausted by scrolling Instagram
mindlessly for 30 minutes and another
person solves that problem by playing
video games for an hour and a third
person solves it by going for a run for
you know 20 minutes and those are all
solutions to the same kind of underlying
problem but some of them are more
healthy or more productive or serve us
better than others and what do you think
the odds are that the solutions you've
come up with to the repeated problems in
your life are the optimal one like it's
just so unlikely that whatever you
happen to have stumbled into throughout
life is the perfect way or the best
habit that serves you most so I think
what I'm trying to get out there is
maybe take a little bit of the pressure
off yourself and don't worry about
judging yourself so much you're just
trying to solve the repeated problems
that you face but once you realize that
it's unlikely that your current
Solutions are the Optimal Solutions well
now maybe we can step outside and above
ourselves and look down and try to come
up with a better solution so rather than
drinking a Coke to get the carbonation
we can drink Sparkling Water so that's
one example for the substitution if we
want to take the other path of reduction
something I've noticed about myself
is if I get a six-pack of beer and I put
it in the the front of the fridge like
in the door or on a shelf that's like
right at a die Level I'll drink one
every night just cuz it's there but if I
take it and put it on the lowest shelf
in the fridge and like it's kind of all
the way back in the corner I can't
really see it unless I'm bending down
it'll sit there for two weeks or three
weeks like and so I'm like did I want it
or not you know like if it was obvious
then I grab one but if it wasn't then I
avoid it and I think that's a simple
question to ask yourself where do I get
my caffeine is it coffee is it soda and
is that really obvious is it like the
coffee sitting right out on the counter
is the the soda like the first thing I
see at eye level when I open the fridge
and how can I make it less obvious in
atomic habits there are kind of what I
call the four laws of behavior change
and it's just this big picture view of
how to build a good habit and so if you
want to build a good habit you want to
make your habits obvious attractive easy
and satisfying and if you want to break
a bad habit you just do the opposite of
those four so you want to make it
invisible make it unattractive make it
difficult and make it unsatisfying can
you give me a a practical application of
that if we just walked through I any
habit doesn't matter I want to establish
can you give me a practical application
of that a strategic application of how I
would do it sure so once we have those
four stages I like to try to
operationalize it how do we make this
actionable how do we apply it to a habit
like you're asking and to do that I've
come up with what I call the four laws
of behavior change and so there's one
law for each stage and if you follow
these they give you kind of like a high
Lev framework for building a good habit
or breaking a bad one so from a real
quick again from a high level the four
laws are the first law is to make it
obvious you want the cues of your good
habits to be obvious available visible
easy to see easier it is for it to get
your attention the more likely you are
to act on it second law is to make it
attractive so again this one connects to
the craving right the more attractive or
appealing or exciting or enticing a
habit is the more likely you are to
perform it the third law is to make it
easy the easier more convenient
frictionless simple a habit is the more
likely you are to do it we've already
talked a little bit about that the
two-minute rule is an example of making
it easy and then the fourth law is to
make it satisfying the more satisfying
or enjoyable or rewarding or pleasurable
habit is the more likely you are to
repeat it so those four laws make it
obvious make it attractive make it easy
make it satisfying they give you a high
level framework for building a habit if
you're ever not sure what to do if you
say how how can I make this more
habitual or how can I you know do a
better job of doing this consistently
you can just go through those four and
ask yourself how can I make it obvious
how can I make it more attractive how
can I make it easier how can I make it
more satisfying and you'll start to find
Opportunities to do those things and of
course the whole book is organized
around sharing different strategies for
doing that let me just give you a couple
personal examples so you can see how
this might be applied when the pandemic
started I knew that I was going to want
to start I was just I wasn't going to
have to be driving or traveling as much
so I wanted to spend that time some that
time I was spending travel tring
previously that I wanted to use it
productively and read more so I uh
opened up my phone and I downloaded
Audible for audiobooks and I moved the
app to the first screen on my phone and
I moved all the other apps to the second
screen so the only thing I saw when I
opened my phone up was audible now
that's a very small thing does not
radically transform your behavior but it
was a way of making reading more obvious
right so that's the first law making it
obvious let me get it in front of me I
also sprinkled books kind of around the
house on my desk like I've got I've
three on my desk right now I have a
couple you know by the bed I've got a
couple in the living room and the point
for me was I never wanted to be far from
a good idea you know like I always
wanted to be kind of surrounded by
something that was interesting or useful
to read and odds are it's more likely
that I pick it up and take a look at it
on the flip side this also applies this
first law of making it obvious it also
applies to many of the bad habits that
we have so for example a lot of people
feel like they watch too much television
but walk into any living room where do
all the couches and chairs face you know
it's like what is this room designed to
get you to do and so I think the
question that you can ask yourself for
this first law making your habits
obvious is what does this space
encourage right what behavior is
encouraged in this area and you want to
design your life design the spaces that
you live and work in to encourage the
good habits and discourage the bad ones
to make the the path of least resistance
or the obvious choice the good habit so
the healthy food is on the counter not
the junk food books are around you not
the TV remote and so on and so forth and
no individual Choice like that is going
to radically transform things but you
can see how making a dozen or two dozen
or 50 little tweaks like that now all of
a sudden you're living in a space that
always is kind of like nudging you
toward the more productive Behavior what
are some of the common reasons why we
struggle with decision- making all kinds
of things that can influence it you know
there's all sorts of biases that we have
like confirmation bias for example is
probably like the one of the most
predominant ones where you're just sort
of searching for evidence that um
supports what you already want to do
rather than trying to find the truth or
figure out the best way to do it I think
one mindset that's good to counter that
is telling yourself I don't care about
being right I care about getting it
right you know like I don't need to be
the one who comes up with the correct
idea as long as we get it correct in the
long run and maybe that gives you a
chance to check your ego a little bit
and search a little more widely for
solution rather than just hoping that
you'll feel good about the process so
you know being wrong nobody likes being
wrong like being wrong is not going to
feel good but if you're wrong in service
of getting it right in the long run then
you know who cares that's fine um so I
think there there are all kinds of
biases like that but generally when I
think about decision- making and trying
to make better choices what does it mean
to make a good choice um it doesn't
necessarily mean that you get the result
that you want it doesn't necessarily
mean that you're always right I think
what it means is that you are
continually improving your position so a
good choice is one that puts you in a
better position for the next cycle the
next round the you know the uncertain
future there's this professor at the
University of Florida he's retired now
he was a photography Professor his name
is Jerry olsman and uh at the beginning
of the semester he would have this film
photography class and he' bring the
class in and he would split them into
two groups he said everybody on this
side of the room you're are going to be
graded on the quantity of work that you
do this uh semester and everybody on
this side of the room you are going to
be graded on the quality of work that
you do this semester and he further
explained it by saying
that for your film photography you're
going to be responsible for having 100
pictures if you do 100 photos over the
course of the semester that'll be an a
if you do 90 it'll be a b if you do 80
it'll be a c and so on so it's quantity
for this group you only have to produce
one photo but it has to be the most
perfect photo that you can make the best
photo that you can make
an interesting an interesting thing
happened at the end of the term all the
best grades came from the quantity group
not from the quality group and what
ended up happening was that while people
were busy experimenting making mistakes
learning how to you know play with
composition and so on they would come
across a really great photo and while
the quality group was busy theorizing
about what Perfection would look like
and how to take the perfect photo and
not actually honing their skills they
ended up only making something mediocre
or average and the important Insight
here especially for habits is that in
the beginning the most important thing
is just to shut up and put your reps in
just make sure that you hone the skill
right and you can start to think of it
the way that I like to think of it is
that any outcome that you wish to
achieve is just a point along the
spectrum of repetitions so if you have
few reps to more reps and you can
imagine an easy goal moderate goal a
hard goal the more reps that you put in
the more that you more like you you are
to achieve that goal so maybe point a is
you know let's take Fitness squatting
100 pounds point B is squatting 200
Point C is quoting 300 maybe you need to
put in 100 reps or 1 th000 reps to get
to point a maybe it's 5,000 to get to
point B maybe it's 10,000 to get to
Point C the Frameworks and principles in
atomic habits are there any sections
chapters principles anything that you
wish more people paid attention to right
there's something that you put
in that gets glossed over or maybe
doesn't stick for whatever reason as
much as other things but you think it or
these things are important well
sometimes you might just be like maybe I
thought that idea was better than it
actually was you know there might be
that too there might be that yeah I I
have a couple so there are two things
that came to mind the first one is
there's a little example I give in the
book about maybe about halfway through
or 40% through where I talk about having
a pregame routine and kind of doing
things in the same sequence each time in
the same Order each time and that helps
get you in the mindset and kind of
initiate the Habit so I you know played
baseball through college and I have the
same pregame routine that I did before
each game and that kind of like flips
this switch in your mind where it's like
hey like it's time to compete now you
know like it's game
mode or the example I gave in the book
was this guy who he would do his writing
at the library and he would go to the
library sit at the same desk each day
and put on his headphones and play the
same playlist and that that little
sequence was a pregame routine that got
him in the mindset to do his writing
habit and one day he turned around and
realized that music was playing he just
had his headphones on and it was just it
was just silent but he was writing and
he was like 20 minutes into writing
before he realized it and it's a good
example of how like just that sequence
of doing it the same W each time and
having that same pregame routine that
little ritual got him in the mindset he
didn't even need to press play that day
he was just ready to write and so if you
can come up with what that little
pregame ritual is for you that can be a
great way to initiate a habit and I
don't usually see people talk about that
I think actually I've heard some
examples like this on on your podcast
previously Tim like I think when you
talked to Josh whiteskin at one point he
at some sometime he gave this example
maybe was in his books maybe it was a
conversation with you where he was
competing this national competition
martial arts and he was told that he was
going to compete at one time and they
came up to him and he was like sleeping
or laying on a on a bench and they were
like hey sorry timing was wrong you're
actually up in like 6 minutes and he was
like normally I would have been thrown
off but he had this little pregame
ritual that he did and he tried to as he
developed it over time it started out
maybe it was 10 minutes and then he
tried to compress it so it was 7 minutes
and then it was 3 minutes and then
eventually got it down to where his
little ritual was just something he did
for like 30 seconds so they woke him up
on that bench and he's got to compete
six minutes later but all he needed was
30 seconds to kind of like get in the
right frame of mind and he was like okay
now I'm ready to go and so those pregame
rituals can be really powerful if you
make it your own and come up with
something that like you do every time
and it helps get you into the mindset
said to compete or to perform one of the
things we often talk about on the
podcast is we all like we Embrace
failure failure is where the learning
happens but it's about getting smart
quickly as well would you tell us a
little bit more about that philosophy
and why it's so important sure well
first a little just a little point on
your uh thought about embracing failure
um I I feel like this is something you
hear from a lot of people who talk about
you know especially like Silicon Valley
startup culture you know fail is almost
praised like you know things like that
and there is an element of truth to it
uh I don't think that you should be
scared of failing because then that
prevents you from reaching that prevents
you from trying but I also think there's
kind of an opposite uh side or another
side of the coin that's important to
emphasize which is you're never trying
to fail like that's not the objective
you know just because it's not like
we're okay with it in the sense that oh
it's fine like I didn't get the result I
wanted that let's just stick with that
you know like I'm I am am in fact trying
to do my best every time I am in fact
trying to figure out a solution that
works I am in fact trying to get an
exceptional result failure is never the
objective um but I'm not scared of it
you know like it's not going to prevent
me from trying and in fact I would say
that actually many people their fear of
failure or their Fe fear of how they'll
be judged or what other people might
think or whether it will appear
impressive enough for you know what
they're hoping to to um instill on the
people around them that General fear
that worry whatever form it takes it
ends up becoming like a break and it pre
it like stops the car it prevents you
from moving forward and my encouragement
is to say listen let fear be the gas
pedal not the break and so and I have
all those same fears you know I'm
worried about what the people who know
me well will think of the next project
I'm going to create I when I started
writing um it I still this is even to
this day I still have never shared an
article that I wrote on my personal
Facebook page with like all the people
who knew me from high school or college
or things like that um and why is that
well now at this point it's because who
cares and I don't use Facebook anymore
but um in the beginning it was because I
was worried about what they would think
I was worried that they would look at it
and be like oh you know look at this
dumb little blog this guy has um and
instead of let s of belonging was ful
then oh for sure mean it's powerful yeah
it's powerful for all of us you know I
mean we all want to belong that's one of
the deepest needs that we all have this
is why those trade-offs are hard to
manage because we all do want to fit in
we all want to connect and also
sometimes people will say things like
well don't don't care what other people
think of you it can be useful in a
context but there's a very good reason
why we care about what other people
think of us which is it tends to serve
you very well when people think well of
you it's it's very beneficial to have
friends to have support not only does it
feel good it also provides you
opportunities it provides you love and
affection it provides you support in
your life that you need so to care what
other people think about you is like
perhaps the most natural thing in the
world to do the question is not whether
to care it's just when to care um so
anyway all of that to say um rather than
letting my worries about what other
people think of me prevent me from
writing or prevent me from creating
instead I just used it as fuel to say
okay listen you just need to get to work
now you know like you you need to put
even more effort into this so that you
can make it truly great so you can
create something that you're proud of
and if you use it as the gas pedal and
not The Brak then it becomes a driver of
creative output rather than a hindrance
for it talk about that a little bit like
you want to be more productive this
article by the way I guys Google it it's
so good it actually teaches you how to
say no as well in the article but are
you good at this or did you write it for
your own benefit well pretty much
everything I write is a reminder to
myself of what I should be doing so uh
no it's not that I'm great at it it's
that I'm trying to learn to be better at
it I felt this very acutely after atomic
habits came out and over the course of
the next the first like three months
that it was out I was doing okay and
then the book really started to take off
and I was constantly feeling like I'm a
very slow learner and that I should have
been upgrading the level at which I was
saying no to things and I was always
like two or three months behind I was
always on the hook for more stuff than I
should have been and it was because I
was saying yes to too many things and
there's this weird dynamic where success
starts to eat itself so the the thing
that was getting me all of these
opportunities is because I was focused
and I wrote a good book and because of
that people were very interested and
talking to me are sharing these new
ideas and like there's all there's all
these interesting new opportunities that
come your way you know do you want to
speak at this thing or what about these
TV rights or how about this interesting
opportunity or would you like to come to
this you know cool conference or Retreat
or whatever and individually each of
them sounds really fun and interesting
but collectively if you start to say yes
to all those things you don't have any
more time to do the thing that got you
those opportunities in the first place
which is thinking clearly and writing a
good book and so uh success like eats
itself all these new opportunities come
in and they squeeze out the thing that
you were good at in the first place so
it's uh I don't know the other thing
that's difficult about it and I still
you know I'm close enough to the
beginning of my career that I can still
appreciate this and feel this for the
first decade of my career I was trying
to say yes to everything I was trying to
capitalize on every opportunity so that
I would have the chance now to say no to
basically everything because you got a
bunch of stuff coming your way so at
first it's like outbound and you're
trying to like capitalize on every
opportunity you can and then there's
this like rapid switch where now all of
a sudden everything's inbound and you
have to put up a tight filter and uh
that can be a difficult lesson to learn
occasionally and this is true for
everybody if you live long enough life
will come for you at some point right
like something's going to happen um so
occasionally life will stress you but
when life doesn't challenge you I think
it's important to challenge yourself
because otherwise you're just living in
this optimal environment air
conditioning and you know everything
else is super easy you can get all the
information the world at your fingertips
you never have to like if you think
about how crazy just eating is in the
modern world so previously when we lived
in tribes you you had to expend energy
to get calories um at a minimum you were
foraging for berries but otherwise you
probably had to like run something down
and kill it or part of a group hunt or
all kinds of other things now you can
get calories without expending any all
you have to do is just tap like Uber
Eats on your phone or something it'll
show up at your door um and you can just
sit on the couch which is of course like
a recipe for uh poor health but also
just it's the game has completely
changed now we've trans sended a lot of
our evolutionary programming and natural
um situations and so you need to be
careful about designing that to serve
you rather than to work against you
because it can very easily nudge you in
the other direction I think there are a
few core habits that are going to serve
everybody and certainly serve me well so
exercise is a huge one um I don't do it
daily but I exercise I train four times
a week and I feel like if I didn't
exercise I don't know that I would be an
entrepreneur like I don't know if I
could handle the psychological roller
coaster without the physical out yeah
the release the you probably feel that
as like an athlete too you know like I
for being an athlete for so many years I
feel like I need to push myself
physically in addition to mentally if
it's just mental it doesn't do it for me
I need to have a physical Outlet so
exercise exercise is one the other the
ultimate meta habit is reading because
if you build a habit of reading you can
solve pretty much any other problem you
know you want learn how to be a better
podcaster you can read about that you
want to learn how to meditate you can
read about that you want to learn how to
make more money you can read about that
um and so what you need is to develop a
habit of reading and then whatever
problem you're facing at the time you
can you have a method for solving that
one of my favorite studies is about
exercise and they had three cohorts in
this study so they have first cohort
they said I just want you to track how
often you work out over the next few
weeks right so that's the the um
standard cohort the control group second
group is said we want you to track off
in you exercise but we're also going to
give you a motivation motivational
speech presentation talk about the
benefits of heart health why habits are
good for you and so on so this is the
motivated group right the third group
they got the same presentation so
they're equally motivated and then they
did one thing differently and that one
thing was they filled out this sentence
they said during the next week I will
partake in at least 20 minutes of
vigorous exercise on this day in this
time at this time in this place right
they specifically stated their intention
to implement the behavior so
implementation intention here's what
happened first group one out of three of
them worked out second group motivation
did nothing as soon as they left the
researchers facility the next day they
weren't motiv it's like reading a book
or watching a YouTube or listening to a
motivational speaker and then you forget
all about it 20 minutes later um but the
third group the group that had a
specific plan for how they were going to
implement the behavior nine out of 10 of
them worked out so you can increase your
odds of success 2 to 3x just by having a
specific plan and this is the Insight
many people think that they lack
motivation when what they really lack is
Clarity they think that they need to get
more motivated that they need willpower
in order to execute on a habit if I just
felt like writing if I just felt like
meditating felt like working out then I
would do it but in fact they don't have
a plan for it and so they wake up each
day thinking I wonder if I'll feel
motivated to write today wonder if I'll
feel motivated to work out today but
instead you can take the decision-
making out of it by explicitly stating
when where and how you want implement
the Habit it sounds easy to say let's
just start a plan let's you know write
down exactly what you should do and then
maybe you'll follow through on it but of
course we all know that there are
challenges that arise it's not quite
that easy so here's a little strategy
that I like to use to make sure you can
come up with a better plan of action and
it's called a failure premortem so the
way that it works is you think about the
Habit the project the goal whatever the
most important thing is that you want to
work on and I want you to imagine fast
forward 6 months from now you failed and
then tell the story of why you failed
what happened what challenges did you
encounter what was it that took you off
course um when I do this with businesses
sometimes we call it the kill the
company exercise because everybody just
sits around and thinks about ways to
kill the company in the next six months
and uh once you have all that stuff laid
down on the table in front of you you
can start to make better choices about
how to develop a plan you can start to
have if then plans so not only do I want
to exercise for 20 minutes on Monday at
5:00 p.m. but also if I do not exercise
because I have to take my kid to
practice or whatever then Tuesday
morning at 7: a.m. I will go in right
you can have ways to adjust for these
challenges I think we actually have like
three options for Breaking Bad Habits so
the first option is to reduce exposure
um so something like you know if you
want to stop spending so much money on
electronics then don't follow all the
latest tech tech review blogs you know
like you're or if you want to lose
weight don't follow a bunch of food
bloggers on Instagram um you're
constantly being triggered by that and
having to like overcome the prompts now
that doesn't always work but if you can
cut a habit off at the source then a lot
of the time like the craving won't arise
uh naturally so in a Tomic habits in the
book I talk a little bit about this
woman who she smoked while she was in
college and she would always smoke while
riding horses with a friend and So
eventually at some point she quit
smoking uh and she also stopped you know
like seeing that friend and graduated
from college so on wasn't riding horses
and then like 10 years later she got
back on a horse for the first time and
suddenly craved a cigarette and um she's
like what is going on here and it's your
habits are often tied to a context
they're tied to a situation or some kind
of cue and so if you can reduce exposure
to that queue then in many cases the
craving won't arise so that's the first
option for breaking a bad habit the
second option which kind of sucks but is
like to sit with the craving long enough
to like let this wave of Desire ride
itself out and and so you basically just
resist temptation um it's possible it's
easier if um if your hand is forced if
you use what I call a commitment device
so brief story real quick Victor Hugo um
famous author who wrote like Hunchback
and notam and a bunch of other things
well when he got the book deal for
Hunchback and notron he just
procrastinated for like a year he hosts
a bunch of House Parties has friends
over he went traveling for a little
while yeah he he like he got the book
deal he did nothing no work um and
eventually his publisher got pissed off
they were like you know can you please
like actually work on this and so they
set this ultimatum for him and they said
uh we're going to we're going to cancel
the book in 6 months if you don't have
it done by then and so he um he got his
assistant to come in put all his clothes
into a chest and they locked him up and
took him out of the house and the only
thing he was left with was like this
this Shaw this like large robe so
basically he had no clothes that were
suitable for hosting guests or for
leaving the house or like going on trips
or anything else so more or less put
himself on house arrest um and what
ended up happening was each time
procrastination arose he was able to
kind of sit with that feeling and let it
ride because he didn't really have many
other options and then get back to work
on the book and it ended up working he
got the book done like two weeks early
but things like that where you can lock
in your future action and it it becomes
really hard to go to your friend's party
or go out to you know travel to a
different place or whatever um just
because you don't have the option if you
can increase the friction then sometimes
you can sit with the craving of a bad
habit and it ride out so that's your
second choice and then the third choice
is the one that you just mentioned which
is you take the solution that the bad
habit is providing the way that it's
serving you and you find a new behavior
that delivers that same outcome what
makes you an expert on habits oh man
based on lots of other people that are
talking about habits I think that and
I've said this many times before I'm
just going through this with everybody
else uh I consider my readers my peers
uh in the sense that we're all just
trying things out the only difference is
I write about what I learn and share it
each week and but we're all just
learning along the way um early on I had
a feeling like that I was like who am I
to you know I'm just a guy who am I to
write about this and I had a friend tell
me the way you develop expertise is by
writing about it every week so I wrote a
new article about habits every Monday
and Thursday for three years and that
was how I developed the expertise on the
topic by writing about it you did
research and you said here's what I
found here's what I tried here's what
worked what didn't work it's a
combination of me reading the scientific
literature and reading the research and
then trying to distill practical
insights from that and testing things
out in my own life as a weightlifter a
Travel Photographer a writer an
entrepreneur and seeing what that looks
like and then the two together and I
think you need both like I don't want to
be some new age version of an academic
who's in an ivory Tower just like
theorizing about ideas is different what
it looks like to put ideas into practice
right like imagine you're a Peak
Performance coach and you show up to
coach like an NBA team these guys are
like dude you need to step on the court
if you know what right to see what it's
actually like in a sense you could say
that every behavior is driven by the
desire for a change in state and so when
you um smoke a cigarette or eat a bag of
Doritos or pick up your phone what you
really want is not the nicotine or the
calories from the Doritos or the um the
likes on social media what you want is
to feel less anxious or to feel approved
or to um not be bored anymore
so it's really the desire to change that
state that you're in that motivates you
to act and the behavior and in many
cases a lot of our modern technology is
an example of this you didn't we didn't
evolve you didn't come out of the womb
with like a desire to check Instagram
right like there's nothing
evolutionarily wired there it's just a
modern manifestation of an ancient
desire to gain respect and approval or
to not be abandoned by the tribe or to
feel approved in you know in some
capacity and uh so we kind of have those
like deeper Primal drives and then the
secondary layer on top of it is just the
modern manifestation of that behavior
and how we're resolving it in the moment
the first stage of every habit is a Quee
the second stage is a craving or some
kind of prediction that your brain makes
I'll give you an example of these in a
second the third stage is the response
and then the fourth stage is the reward
so you walk into a um the question I had
that that no model I could find could
solve in in any good way or explain in
any good way was why can the same person
respond to the same CU in a different
way so let's say you get into the habit
of going to the gym at 5:00 every day
but then sometimes work gets busy and
you don't go to the gym at 5:00 current
models don't explain that very well
because it's like well the Q is five you
should be going to the gym right now it
says you the routine follows
automatically after the queue um or why
uh why does someone walk into the
kitchen and see a plate of cookies and
then they automatically want to eat it
but you could just as imagine uh just as
easily imagine that you just got done
eating dinner in the other room and
you're stuffed and you're full and you
walk in you see a plate of cooking
you're like I'm stuffed I don't want to
eat anything so what's going on there
and I think these four stages explain it
which is you see the queue or you
experience a queue and then your craving
or your prediction differs based on your
current state so the way that you
interpret the cues in your life is
contingent upon the current state that
you're in the way you're feeling right
um and also other things like your
beliefs or your identity the social
group that you're part of right so like
if you're in a different group then
maybe you interpret things in a
different way um you know you could
imagine one group they practice a
particular religion they walk into a
butcher shop and see pork and they don't
they're like oh we can't eat that right
another person walks in and they're like
oh yeah I'll have a pork sandwich
because it's obvious and easy and right
there um so what you choose is
contingent upon how you interpret the
cues in your life you don't have to be
the victim of your environment you can
also be the architect of it you can
decide to design something to make your
good behaviors easier and your bad
behaviors harder so when it comes to
habits if you want to practice your
guitar more frequently put it right in
the middle of your living room so you
run across all the time if you want to
read more when you make your bed in the
morning take the book you want to read
put it on top of the pillow when you
come back that night pick it up read a
few pages go to sleep for me I uh I used
to buy apples all the time and then I
would put them in the crisper at the
bottom of the fridge and they would sit
there for 3 weeks and go bad and I'd
finally open it up and see them again
and get mad and then eventually I bought
a bowl and put it right in the middle
the counter and so then when I buy
apples I put them there I see them every
day and now I eat them all the time um
many of our desires are simply shaped
because we have an environment that
shapes Us in that way so the moral of
the story is I've never seen someone
stick to positive habits in a consistent
fashion in a negative environment maybe
you can overpower it once or twice maybe
you can have the willpower to do the
right thing on one day but if you're
constantly fighting against those forces
it's going to be very hard to follow
through people have heard things like
this before start small small steps
whatever but even when you know you
should should start small it's still
really easy to start too big so U you
know say you want to get in shape and
you're like all right I want to run a
couple days a week but I know I should
start small so I'll only run for 15
minutes but even that is like way bigger
than what I'm talking about I mean it
should be so small that you in the book
I called the two-minute rule but you
should downscale any Habit to fit within
2 minutes so it's like all right I want
to go for a run three days a week my
habit is I put on my running shoes and I
step out the door anything else that
happens after that is just bonus
success now sometimes people resist that
because they're like well this sounds
kind of like a mental trick right like I
know the real goal isn't just to put my
shoes on and know the real goal is to go
for a run so if you feel that way my
suggestion would be only do the first
two minutes for the first few weeks
because what you need to do is Master
the art of showing up like I had a I had
a reader who ended up losing over 100
pounds and one of the things that he did
was he went to the gym but he wasn't
allowed to stay for longer than five
minutes so he would show up be there do
like half an exercise five minutes would
go he'd leave he did this for like six
weeks wow now it sounds ridiculous it
sounds silly cuz the opposite just work
out for a half hour yeah yeah but what
he was doing was mastering the art of
showing up and a habit must be
established before it can be improved
right if you don't establish the Habit
there's nothing to optimize if you're
not showing up at the gym every day you
don't even who cares about what workout
you're doing you're not even there don't
start running an hour a day if you've
never run in a long time be the person
who shows up and puts their running
shoes on every day before you worry
about how far you're running and what
kind of workout you're doing and all
that type of stuff there's this thing
called good heart's law that says a
measure ceases to be a good measure when
it becomes the Target and so the point
is like imagine you're trying to lose
weight uh if you use the scale as a
measurement as a data point then yeah it
can be useful as like one signal into
your overall health but if it becomes
the target if the whole mission of
getting in shape becomes about making
the scale go lower well then you start
doing a lot of unhealthy things just to
get the scale to move um you know you
may sack you may do some crazy juice
cleanse or some kind of radical diet or
um you end up doing unhealthy things in
the name of moving the number and I
think that there's a lot of application
to that in creativity and business as
well if the number becomes the target
then uh you kind of lose sight of the
bigger picture and so I I feel like I
try to remind myself that measurements
are just a a piece of the larger puzzle
and I can use them to inform and make
sure I'm moving in the right direction
but don't spend too much time obsessing
over any indiv metric why is something
rewarding why do you find it rewarding
and one of the reasons is because it
satisfies the craving that preceded the
action so um one way to put this is that
perceived value motivates you to act
actual value motivates you to repeat so
it when you buy something on Amazon you
don't actually buy the product like you
don't you don't buy the book cuz you
don't actually have it yet what you buy
is the image the product creates in your
mind you buy your expectation or the
perceived value of the sales page um
it's only after you get the book and you
read it and you're like oh this is
really good that's when the actual value
it satisfies that craving you had before
and it reinforces oh hey this was
enjoyable I should do it again next time
um so you kind of have both of those on
on each side of the the behavior is
there such thing as I guess Central
habits that can help to shift and
transform other aspects of your life cuz
that's something that I've noticed
little bit where if I start eating
better or if I start going to the gym
every day it's almost like a domino or
ripple effect where these other habits
start to pick up naturally because I'm
starting to feel better so like cuz I've
been going to the gym 5 days a week so
now when I come home I don't feel like
binging out on junk food I feel like
eating better food or if I wake up early
uh is that something you've noticed in
your research yeah sure so there are two
ways to answer this question so the
first way is um what you're describing
is often sometimes called a keystone
habit uh the idea is you do one thing
and it like ripples into other areas of
your life and so for me it's exercise
like if I go to the gym then I get the
benefits of exercise but I also tend to
eat better I like for some reason I just
don't want to waste it um I also focus
more so I have sort of that like
post-workout High uh after I after I
work out uh and then I sleep better
because I'm tired from the workout which
means I wake up the next morning and I
have better energy um and at no point
was I trying to build better sleep
habits or energy habits or Focus habits
or nutition habits but all that kind of
just came as a side effect of doing this
one thing of going to the gym some other
common uh Keystone habits are budgeting
sometimes people say when they pay off
debt you'll then they'll like start to
get in shape or they um you know build
they're more social and have better
relationships like there's all kinds of
things that kind of come out of that um
going for daily walk is a really big one
it's very common one among creators in
particular there's a book called daily
rituals by Mason cury and he basically
just writes down like what I don't know
it's 100 or 150 famous like creators and
scientists and whatever what their daily
routines were and a lot of them were
raging alcoholics and on amphetamines
and all kinds of other stuff but the
ones who uh were more healthy a daily
habit a daily habit like walking was a
really big part of their routine um
visualization is a big one especially
for performers like a comedian or
something they'll often visualize the
same kind of result or professional
athletes uh before they step out on the
stage or step out on the court this is a
real Pitfall for a lot of people with
habits is they have this like All or
Nothing mentality they'll like start
this diet and then they go binge with
their friends for you know like a happy
hour or something uh and then they're
like oh well you know I blew the diet
guess I shouldn't even bother right and
I think that this is um this is a mantra
that I like to keep in mind with habits
I mean the truth is every habit streak
is going to end at some point you know
like when I when I launched my site I
wrote a new article every Monday and
Thursday for three years but then I
signed this book deal and I needed to
change that and so that streak ended and
you've probably had a variety of times
this year where you've done meditation
for 5 days in a row or 7 days in a row
or 12 days in a row but then at some
point that streak broke and the key is
never miss twice you know like if you
get back on if you can get back on track
quickly then that's a huge win um I've
seen this in a lot of areas now as I've
started to study people who are like top
performers whether it's sports or
business but it's it's not that they
make they don't make mistakes people at
the top levels they make mistakes too
but they just get back on qu back on
track more quickly um so it's it's
almost never the first mistake that
ruins you it's like the spiral of
repeated mistakes that follows um I
think in the book I have a line
something like missing once is a mistake
missing twice is the start of a new
habit and what you don't want is to
start that new habit you want to never
miss twice and just get back on track as
quickly as possible and if you can keep
that in mind um it can end up being
pretty powerful for consistency you know
it's like even if you only did that if
you never missed twice if you did it and
then missed and they're like well I'm
not going to miss twice you did it again
and then you missed and then you do it
at least 50% of the time um so anyway
yeah I think that's uh that says
something about your mentality that you
keep coming back to it even though every
now and then it doesn't work out in
order to change Behavior design it in
any meaningful way you need to be aware
of it first but usually when people
become aware of their habits or think
about them you know like you might smoke
or bite your nails or something on
autopilot but then if you start to think
about it well you feel guilty about it
you know you start to judge yourself as
soon as you start to judge yourself then
you're not in a great position to change
because you what ends up happening a lot
of the time this has happened actually
with a couple campaigns uh that have
tried to scare smokers into not smoking
by showing them pictures of blacken
lungs or Scare obese people into not
eating as much by talking about the the
detriment of being overweight what
happens is people get really anxious and
stressed they feel guilty and worried
and then they Resort they resort to
their preferred habit for dealing with
that which means they end up smoking
more or eating more or whatever so uh
yes I think there is a benefit to
looking at it in an unemotional forensic
way um and one way to do that is to say
there are no good or bad habits uh there
are just behaviors that serve you in a
particular way and the goal is to try to
find a behavior that serves you in a
better way I'll give you an example of a
good habit and a bad habit so for good
habits you want the physical environment
to make it obvious and easy for you to
do the behavior you know so like I um
like have a pull-up bar in your room
you're trying to do 100 pull-ups a day
like have it hanging over your door as
opposed to even if you had one but it
was in the closet because you just half
the time you wouldn't remember take it
out or it's at the gym upstairs or down
the street no um you know I have a
friend who he wanted to practice uh
guitar more and so he left his guitar in
the middle of his living room and that
just so he'd walk past it aund times a
day it up Andes much easier right bad
habits are the same way um so but in
Reverse instead of making it obvious you
want to make it invisible um you know
take like which is just talking about
video games a lot of people feel like
they watch too much spend too much time
watching TV or playing video games or
watching a screen but if you walk into
pretty much any living room where do all
the couches and chairs face they all
face the television so it's like what is
that room designed to get you to do turn
it on yeah so you can restructure that
environment to make it less likely that
you'll fall into that habit and there
are a variety of things you could do you
could take the remote control and put it
inside like a drawer so you don't see it
you could put the television behind a
wall unit or cabinet so that it's less
visible but you could also increase the
friction with the task so you could like
unplug your TV after each use and only
plug it back in if you can say the name
of the show that you want to watch so
you can't like mindlessly pull up
Netflix and just find something um or
you could take the batteries out of the
remote control so that it's an extra
like 5 to 10 seconds to turn on and
maybe that's enough time to be like do I
really want to watch something right now
am I just doing this mindlessly yeah um
if you really want to be extreme don't
have a TV yes you could get rid of the
TV entirely or take it off the wall and
put it in the closet and only take it
out when you really want to watch
something this is one of the most common
uh I guess criticisms or complaints that
people ask me about with habits is like
well you know I don't want to be robotic
right like I what what about like
spontaneity what about the you know
freedom and doing what I want you know I
don't want to like pigeon hole myself in
this lifestyle but uh it's this false
dichotomy because habits don't restrict
Freedom they create it you know it's
often the people who have the worst
habits that have the least amount of
Freedom it's the people who have
terrible financial habits that are
always wondering like where the next
dollar will come from or it's the people
who have poor learning habits that are
always one like feeling like they're
behind the curve um or people who have
poor Fitness habits that are always
struggling to find energy but on the
other hand if you have your habits
dialed in if you like you know have your
your Fitness habits figured out if
you've got your finances handled then
you actually have way more freedom than
you did before now you actually have the
space to you have the energy to do what
you want you have the strength to do
what you want you have the financial
ability to spend time in areas that you
want um and all of that comes from
getting your habits handled so it's it's
uh it is a little counterintuitive this
idea that like discipline equals Freedom
or habits do not restrict Freedom they
created but it's it's true that if you
can handle that stuff if the
fundamentals of Life are dialed in then
you've got space for spontaneity and
creativity and freedom and all the other
stuff every behavior is followed by some
kind of outcome it's just basic cause
and effect um and if the immediate
outcome is favorable is enjoyable you
have a reason to repeat it in the future
it's kind of like donuts M yeah exactly
right it's like that example if you if
you um if you feel good if you feel
satisfied right after you do something
then it's like this positive emotional
signal and it's like yeah I should do
this again yeah so you can see this
actually business is a really
interesting example with this there are
a lot of products some of the most
successful products have some type of
immediate satisfaction that is layered
into them so uh toothpaste is a very
common example there's no reason a
toothpaste needs to taste like mint but
it does because the minty flavor and the
refreshingness of it it makes your it
gives your mouth this clean feel it's
more satisfying so you have a reason to
do it again in the future um I heard an
interesting one recently about car
manufacturers that some of them are
adding a fake guttural Roar to the the
car or the truck when you press the
accelerator because it just adds to the
actual natural sound of the engine so it
makes it more satisfying to step on the
gas and to drive the car so there are a
variety of examples like this but if you
can add an the key is it needs to be
immediate right so like this is um in
the book I refer to this as the cardinal
rule of behavior change which is
behaviors that are immediately rewarded
get repeated behaviors that are
immediately punished get avoided and
it's really about the speed of how
quickly you feel successful if it feels
good you have a reason to do it again um
is that why video games do so well video
games are Masters At This they're
Masters at it so um their masters
actually at a variety of of aspects
related to Habit formation so one is is
they're really good at this immediate
satisfaction there are all kinds of
things you're actually constantly
getting feedback in a video game even if
you're just running you hear the pitter
patter of the steps it's that's
gratifying it's yeah the jingles of like
picking up another power up or um you
know seeing a kill or something like
that whatever the game is you're always
getting constant feedback sound uh
things that are on screen they're really
good at dripping that watching the the
score increase in the top Corner that is
immediate feedback um so they they have
all these different ways of making you
feel satisfied and when you see that
progress you have a reason to continue
in the future this is one of the one of
the most effective forms of immediate
satisfaction is progress soon as you
feel progress you have a reason to
continue feels really good to see that
you're making Headway my publisher told
me uh there's something to the effect of
like we write the Books we need
ourselves and that's uh it's funny
because you know when I write about
habits a lot of people assume that I
have my habits so dialed in because I'm
the guy writing about but I'm writing
about it to learn about it you know I'm
writing about it to try to improve I
consider my readers and myself to be
peers right we're all just kind of
experimenting and operating and and
working on stuff and uh the only
difference is I just share the lessons
when I learn them um so yeah I um I
definitely had an internal desire for
that uh and then there have been a
variety of areas in my life where I've
had to implement that Athletics um
photography uh writing and building a
business of course and all of those have
been kind of like test labs for me to to
put the ideas into practice right but
why zero in on this on habits
yeah well I think that a little bit of
it comes back to what you just mentioned
a few minutes ago about how important
habits are uh I didn't know this at
first so I was a baseball player for
many years and as any athlete can tell
you there are all kinds of habits that
you have at practice rituals things like
that and I was benefiting from that um
you know my strength coach would tell me
to do something or my coaches would hold
me accountable to certain habits and
that would help pull the rest of my life
in line you know I always did better in
school when I had Sports as well uh it
would it would like give me something to
Anchor my day around and so I knew that
it was working but I didn't have a
language for it um and so it was only
until maybe 5 years after my career
ended and I finished graduate school and
I started like looking into this stuff a
little bit more that I started to come
across the science of habit formation
and behavior change and developed a
language for it and started to write
about it so I kind of implicit knew it
was important but didn't discover that
uh the actual way to write about until
later now the second thing here though
is that I as I dug into the topic more I
started to like unearth these layers and
realize wow this is actually even more
important than I thought and this comes
back to the point that you made a few
minutes ago which is that habits are one
of the phrases I'd like to use is that
pretty much any of the results in your
life are a lagging measure of your
habits right so your weight is a lagging
measure of your eating habits your
bank account is a lagging measure of
your financial habits your clutter is a
lagging measure of your cleaning Habits
Like the outcomes are just the the
manifestation of the behaviors that
preceded them right um so you kind of
get what you repeat in that way well
that makes sense people understand that
that's important so that's one reason
why habits are are crucial but there's
another thing that habits do that is
even more Central even more important
and that is that your habits are the way
that you embody a particular identity so
every morning that you make your bed you
embody the habits of you embody the
identity of an organized person someone
who's clean every time you go to the gym
you embody the identity of someone who
is fit every time you sit down to write
a sentence or a page uh you embody the
identity of someone who is a writer and
so in that sense habits are like every
action you take is kind of like a vote
for the type of person that you believe
that you are and as you take these
actions you build up evidence
of a particular identity and pretty soon
your beliefs have something to like root
themselves in it's like man I you know I
showed up at the gym for 4 days a week
for the last three months I guess like
I'm the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts um and that I think is the true
reason why habits are so important uh
once I realized how beliefs and
behaviors are connected that it's like
this two-way street um then I've started
to think all right maybe this is really
something not only does it deliver those
external results the clean room or the
you know bigger bank account but also
the internal results of shaping your
sense of self-image and what you believe
let's say that you wanted to build a
better I'll give you I'll give you an
example breaking a good H or building a
good habit and breaking a bad one so one
of the laws is to make it obvious and
this largy comes down to like what we're
exposed to each each day and minimalism
and simplicity plays a big role in this
um in the book I call it environment
design that's basically the strategy so
for a long time I realized that I
brushed my teeth twice a day but I
didn't floss consistently and when I
looked at that habit one of the reasons
that I wasn't flossing consistently is
because the floss was hidden in the
drawer in the bathroom so I just
wouldn't see it you know like I wouldn't
open up the drawer and remember so I
bought a little bowl and got some of the
pre-made flossers and put them in the
bowl and plac it right next to my
toothbrush so now I brushed my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all I needed to do uh to build the habit
of flossing every day um on the other
side let's say you know a lot of people
feel like they spend too much time
watching TV or playing video games or
just looking at a screen but if you walk
into pretty much any living room where
do all the couches and chairs face they
all face the television so it's like
what is that room designed to get you to
do it's designed to get you to watch TV
so there are a variety of uh levels to
this you could for example uh take the
remote and take it off of the coffee
table and put it inside a drawer or you
could take the television and put it
inside like a wall unit or a cabinet so
you don't see it um you could also
increase the friction of the task so you
could like take the batteries out of the
remote um after each use and then you
know it's an extra 5 or 10 seconds put
it in maybe that's just enough time for
you to think do I really want to watch
something or am I just doing this
mindlessly you could um unplug the TV
after each individual use and then only
plug it in if you can say the name of
the show you want to watch so you can't
like mindlessly browse on
Netflix and I mean if you really wanted
to be extreme about it you could take
the TV off the wall put it in the closet
and then only take it out when you
really wanted to watch something but the
point here and this is kind of the the
principle of environment design in
general which is you want to put fewer
steps between you and the good behaviors
and more steps between you and the bad
ones and imagine the cumulative impact
of living an environment that exposes
you to the cues of your positive habits
and reduces the cues of your negative
habits it's kind of like you're just
gently being nudged in the right
direction each day and that's just one
of the of the ways that you can sort of
design a system that leads you into
better habits just take someone who's
trying to get in shape I mean people
will
what kind of protein powder should I get
what knee sleeves do I need what what
are the best uh weightlifting shoes and
all that stuff is like the last 2% of
difference it's mostly like don't miss
workouts and get your reps in this is
what in the book I call the difference
between motion and action uh action can
actually deliver a result uh but motion
is related to that but never will um you
know like going to the gym and uh
talking to a personal trainer about
signing up that's fine that's related to
getting in shape but it doesn't matter
how many times you talk to a personal
trainer you're never going to get in
shape uh whereas like doing 10 squats
that actually can do something it's like
talking to the trainer as motion doing
squats as action um and yeah I think a
lot of times people get trapped in
motion they get trapped in analysis
paralysis because it uh is a way to feel
like you're making progress without
running the risk of failure there are
some experiences in life that have to be
lived to be understood fully uh not
everything is like that but some things
do and that's that's one thing that's
challenging I think about there's a nval
rant investor he's got a quote where he
says something to the effect of um good
decisions come from experience and uh
experience comes from bad decisions so
basically you like you got to kind of
like try and fail and then you learn and
that's that's how it happens all about
lessons um so part of that I think is
unavoidable that's just how it Go nobody
is going to make perfect decisions
throughout life and hopefully um you
know an unexamined failure only remains
a failure an examined failure can become
an
a success so hopefully you're at least
learning when you make the bad choices
every day I try to leave my phone in
another room outside of my office at
least until lunch because then I get
like a 4H hour block of time in the
morning where I can just work without
any distraction and um it's funny how
quickly you don't like if my phone was
on me in the morning I would check it
like you know every 5 minutes or
whatever but when it's out of the room I
don't even find myself wanting to I
never walk up the stairs to go check it
even though it's only 30 seconds away
wow so it's it's interesting how um
little we actually want to do these
things but we just do them all the time
because they're obvious and easy and I
think the key is to invert that take the
things that are the bad habits the
distractions the procrastinations the
unproductive uses of time and make them
more invisible reduce exposure and less
uh less easy to do and take the things
that are good habits and make it the
equivalent of having your phone on you
all the time right make it right in
front of you make it obvious make it
easy make it um you know frictionless
what really changes your your outcomes
or what really moves your life in a
positive direction is not a single like
1% change or a single uh little habit
it's a collection of them all organized
towards the same like overall goal or
overall outcome so you know sometimes
people will they get like a you know a
Fitbit and they start they get a Fitbit
and they start walking 10,000 steps a
day or something like that and then they
get frustrated after 3 months because
they haven't seen this change in the
mirror this change on the scale or
whatever but it's like well that's good
but that's just one one habit related to
your health you don't need um you don't
need a single little habit you need like
a thousand of them and once you kind of
build this collection of them all moving
you in the same direction it's kind of
like each one adds a little grain of
sand to the side of the scale and
eventually you tip the scales in your
favor and I think that's another reason
to start with one habit at a time is
that you naturally sort of pick up other
behaviors that are related to the
overall thing that you're working on in
the moment and um and that helps keep
you focused rather than trying to do two
or three things and then you get
scattered if your expectations are
Skyhigh um you know like if you set I
have a a friend who's a writer and he
his goal is to write one sentence every
day um and it sounds absurd but if you
set the expectation that low then he can
feel successful pretty much every day he
always can feel satisfied by sticking to
the Habit which gives him a reason to
come back again the next day and
sometimes he writes a full page and
sometimes it's just a sentence but um if
he had set a goal of writing a thousand
words a day there would be some days
where he couldn't do that and then
suddenly he's feeling bad about that
like what if he wrote one sentence that
day he would feel bad about it even
though he still wrote that day but it's
just because of his expectation so
there's a little bit of like mental play
that's going on there in how we kind of
we sabotage ourselves by setting the bar
so high that's especially true in the
beginning I think that it becomes less
true for maybe the one or two areas
where you really want to be a master in
life like if something's really
important to you and you want PE
performance you want to be a
professional athlete you want to be uh
you know among the Best Authors or
something like that then maybe uh your
strategy needs to change but for most
people most of the time the strategy is
probably better to set the bar low find
a way to be satisfied and show up each
day and then once youve built the Habit
then you optimize from there this is um
I had a a reader who end up losing over
100 pounds and one of the things that he
did was he went to the gym um but he
wasn't allowed to stay for longer than
in 5 minutes and so it sounds so weird
because it's a complete opposite of what
most people do to build a habit but he
what he was doing was he was mastering
the art of showing up um and so for six
weeks he went to the gym he'd go in do
like half an exercise and then 5 minutes
would be up and he go home and
eventually you got to the point where he
was like you know I'm coming here all
the time I kind of feel like staying
longer right but that's that's the
opposite of the person who takes the
intermediate CrossFit class and like
kills themselves for 3 weeks and then it
feels totally fried and you know gives
up and then 3 months later they're like
oh I got to get back in shape
um and so a habit must be established
before it can be improved right often we
optimize for the Finish Line we think
about the outcome that we want we think
about like oh I want to lose 20 pounds
or I want to earn six figures this year
whatever the the thing is um but instead
if you just focus on the first two
minutes of a behavior or in this guy's
case the first five minutes of the
behavior and you optimize for the
starting line you master the art of
showing up but then you have options
then you can you actually have something
that you can improve if you're not the
type of person who shows up at the gym
uh even if it's just for 5 minutes it
doesn't even matter what your ideal
workout plan is or whatever like you
can't do anything because you're not
there and so um in that sense I think
that it's often helpful for people
especially in the beginning to scale a
habit down to the first two minutes
Master the art of showing up and then
once you're the type of person who does
it every day figure out a way to improve
in my personal life you know like
there's a moment around 5:15 each night
my wife gets home from work and either
we change into our workout clothes and
we go to the gym or we don't change into
our workout clothes and we watch you
know reruns the office and Order take
out or whatever and really the next two
hours are kind of determined by that
decisive moment of whether we change
into our workout clothes or not if we
change a clothes then like everything
else is going to happen automatically
we're going to drive to the gym I'll get
under the bar I'll do it's already pred
decided basically so one of the
realizations of this and it comes back
to your kind of central question of what
you know what are the most important
habits to build or there ones that
Ripple into other areas of life if you
can just Master maybe five or 10
decisive moments throughout the day
these little kind of two-minute chunks
that determine the next block of time
you really only have to focus your
attention and energy on that and the the
the rest of it kind of comes easily you
don't have to do that much uh if you can
Master the right moments it's kind of
like Judo for your personal habits you
know you apply the pressure in the right
place and everything else kind of Falls
in in line the reason a lot of people
struggle with that conscious activity is
that they pick things that are too big
in the beginning right I call lower
lower the bar yeah right so the
two-minute rule helps you lower the bar
by saying a new habit should is
something that should take less than two
minutes to do so you take whatever habit
you're trying to build whatever
ambitious plan you have read 40 books a
year becomes read one page or do yoga
four days a week becomes take out my
yoga mat and sometimes people resist
this a little bit when I say it first
cuz they think all right well I know the
real goal isn't just to like take my
yoga mat out I know I actually want to
do the workout and if I know that and
it's like this mental trick and I know
it's a trick why would I fall for it and
so my suggestion if you feel that way is
force yourself for the first few days to
only do it for 2 minutes I forget which
study it was it is said something along
the lines it was a dietary study if you
said I can't have that food oh yeah you
were far more likely to eat it than if
you said I don't eat that food I this
one that's a decision right I think it
was in Ferris is 4-Hour
Body yeah they brought people in they
did this they had them do like test that
uh was just fake uh you know it's just
they they thought that was the actual
experiment but of course in Psychology
experiments it's never the actual
experiment but anyway as they walked out
of the room they offered them either a
chocolate bar or um uh some healthy I
don't know healthy uh snack a gr a bar
or something I don't know anyway but
during the test they had had to either
repeat phrases or fill out phrases that
were like uh I don't eat ice cream or I
don't you know um Miss workouts or
things like that or I won't or I can't
yeah I don't or I can't I can't eat ice
cream I can't work out I can't miss a
workout that kind of thing and all the
people who said I can't who felt
restrictive were far more likely to opt
for the chocolate bar uh than the people
who said I don't which again comes back
to this form of identity um you know
imagine uh this is an example I
mentioned in the book imagine you have
two people who are trying to quit
smoking and you offer both of them a
cigarette and the first person says oh
no thanks I'm trying to quit and the
second person says oh no thanks I'm not
a smoker same thing they're both turning
down cigarette but the first person
still identifies as a smoker they
identify as someone who's trying to do
something that isn't them whereas the
other person signals the shift in
identity oh no thanks I'm not a smoker
they no longer see themselves in that
way and it's one thing to say I'm the
type of person who wants this it's
another thing to say I'm the type of
person who is this and in a sense true
Behavior change is actually identity
change because once you believe that
that's who you are you're not even
really trying to change your habits
anymore you're just acting in alignment
with the type of person you already
believe yourself to be it's like no I'm
the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts so I'm not I'm not like
convincing myself to go to the gym
that's just who I am I just work out you
know um
so uh identity change is is at the root
of pretty much all Behavior change
social norms Society leans heavily on us
all so uh if you there are just broad
examples of this pressure religious
pressure media pressure pressure
everything um let's say so just some
broad examples uh you walk into an
elevator and you turn around to face the
front you have a job interview and you
wear a suit and tie or a dress or
something nice there's no reason it has
to be that way right like you could face
the back of the elevator you could wear
a swimsuit to a JV interview but you
don't do that because it violates the
shared Norms of the group right it
violates the shared expectations of what
that Society has but that's not that's
true not only in a broad sense that
we're part part of these tribes like big
tribes you know what it means to be a
Christian or to be American or to be
Australian or whatever but it's also
true in the small tribes that we belong
to what it means to be a neighbor on
this street or a member of your local
CrossFit gym or to volunteer for a local
organization all of those tribes all of
those groups that you belong to have a
set of shared expectations a set of
shared norms and the key if you want to
build habits that last if you want to
change the way that you interpret cues
is to join a group where you're the
desired behavior is the normal behavior
right like there are there are plenty of
people who they want to work out but
going to the gym feels like a lot to
them uh feels hard feels like a
sacrifice but there are also people who
go to the gym every week and it's just
normal it doesn't feel like an
obligation that's the desired behavior
is the normal behavior their lifestyle
right same thing for uh musicians you
know like if you want to learn an
instrument hang out with people who play
all the time you know like if you hang
out with a bunch of musicians it's like
well yeah what we do all we play four
days a week if we play seven days a week
because it just happens that's that's
what the tribe does the caveat to this
and the thing that I don't see people
mention a lot is that the reason social
norms influence our Behavior so much is
because we want to belong to the tribe
we want to be friends with those people
and so we don't want to lose the
friendship or lose belonging over
violating the Norms yeah you're not
going to hang out with a bunch of vegans
and have pork right and just like be the
only one eating that you won't hang out
with them for very long cuz you're not
going to be friends with them anymore
right they'll kick you out so you want
to to the standard of that group of that
community so the key I think is to join
a group where your desired behavior is a
normal behavior and you already have
something else in common with that group
so uh Steve cam is a good example of
this so like Steve runs nerd Fitness
right and all these people want to get
in shape who are coming into his
community but they also love Star Wars
or Batman or Spider-Man or you know all
these other things that nerds are into
and if you show up it can be
intimidating to want to get in shape or
you know work out the first time but if
if you can connect with the group over
your mutual love of Star Wars then
you're like oh well I'm friends with
these people and now I also want to pick
up those other habits with them because
I want to belong with the group because
we're already friends and so I think you
can apply that methodology to most um
new tribes that you join don't just join
a new tribe because they have the
desired Behavior also try to find a way
that you can overlap with them find some
shared context stuff too that you can
Bond over and then it's easier to adopt
the habits musicians that like to be
healthy yeah if you want to do both
right it's like that even subgroup it's
like hey we love you know we love
playing music and then also you're going
to start eating better because we all
want to eat healthy this is coming from
someone who's been very goal oriented
for a long time so I would set goals for
the grades I wanted to get in school or
the weights I wanted to lift in the gym
or the amount of Revenue I wanted in my
business or how many email subscribers I
wanted like all of that and at some
point I realized you know I'm setting
all these goals like am I actually
achieving some of them and sometimes I
would but there were plenty of times
where I failed and so I had this
realization that well if that's the case
then setting a goal cannot be the thing
that means whether or not I achieve
success and if you think about this the
winners and losers in any domain a lot
of the time they have the same goals you
know like every person who applies for a
job has the goal of getting the job um
every Olympian has the goal of winning
the gold medal and so if winners and
losers have the same goals then the goal
can't be the thing that makes the
difference um and I don't mean that
goals are useless I think goals are
actually quite useful for setting a
sense of direction or knowing um you
know which basically what area the the
boat should be pointed in what direction
the boat should be pointed in where
you're trying to row but once you've
decided that it's probably more useful
to put the goal on the shelf and focus
exclusively on the system or the process
and um in my language habits make up the
system and uh they're like this
collection of H of behaviors and
patterns that you perform each day and
when you put them all together you end
up with this system that delivers a
result and whatever your results are in
Life or in business or wherever your
current system is perfectly designed to
deliver them it has to be by definition
that's why you're getting those results
so if you want different results what
you need is not really a different goal
we need is a different system habits
allow you to solve the problems of life
with less energy and effort than you
would otherwise need and you know all
life requires energy to exist if you if
you don't have energy then you don't
survive and so energy is very precious
for that reason and your brain is
looking for ways to conserve it whenever
possible um you know this makes just
logical sense right like if you imagine
like our ancestors living on the
Savannah if you could forage for berries
in a patch that's 100 meters away then
why would you bother forging for berries
in a patch that's like 10,000 meters
away or on the other side of the
mountain or whatever right like you're
going to seek the path of least
resistance to get the results that you
want and habits are sort of a a shortcut
a mental shortcut that your brain uses
to to do that kind of thing on a daily
basis so take for example the habit of
tying your shoe um the first time you do
it you don't know how to tie your shoe
and you have to think carefully about
how to make the knots and someone has to
teach you how to do it and so on but
after you do it 100 times or a thousand
times or 10,000 times pretty soon you
can tie your shoes while you're talking
to somebody or thinking about your to-do
list for the day um you just pretty
pretty much can do it on autopilot and
so in a small sense tying a shoe is like
a problem that you face on a daily basis
and your brain has automated the
solution and habits allow you to do that
in all different areas of life all the
time you automate the solutions to the
recurring problems in life which means
you can focus on other things and direct
your attention elsewhere so for that
reason habits are like so Central to our
experience that we often Overlook them
like you don't even really think about
brushing your teeth or tying your shoes
or unplugging the toaster after each use
or all these other things you do each
day but your habits are the thing that
help you function and operate in the
world in a more efficient manner manner
we interpret the stimuli and the data
the uh cues in our life differently
based on what our Viewpoint is at that
time based on what our personality or
our uh sorry not our personality our
personal Viewpoint is based on what you
believe your self-image so you know I
mean you see this all the time with
politics you have the same news story
that runs on the TV but then a liberal
and a conservative interpret that data
in completely different ways and it's
because of uh what's getting echoed back
to them because of how they see
themselves because of what filter
they're running that data through and
the same thing is true if we're talking
about weight loss or whatever else you
know if like you see a particular number
on the scale and the thing that's being
echoed back to you is I want to lose 20
pounds and feel great then suddenly you
don't feel good about that number if the
same thing if the uh thing that's
getting echoed back to you is I've stuck
to workouts for seven days in a row and
I feel more energetic and healthy then
you see the number in a totally
different way same number uh just
different interpretation so I think it
it's important uh but it's not the whole
story um and some of the the things that
also influence things are you know like
what we talked about making things
obvious and making them easy um but
making it satisfying the which is The
Fourth Kind of major lever that I talk
about in the book that's crucial for
getting people to come back um and that
can come in many different forms um
there's a so I I guess I'll just lay the
context for this real quick there this
is really interesting to look at with a
lot of products um so chewing gum is a
good example for many years for hundreds
of years chewing gum was around but it
was like kind of this Bland resin it was
just chewy but it wasn't tasty and rley
launched in like 1880 1890 and they came
out with Juicy Fruit and spearmint and
double Min and suddenly gum was chewy
and it had this immediate flavor there
was like this immediate reward to
chewing it and it took off they became
the biggest chewing gumy chewing gum
company in the world um and today many
companies are doing the same kind of
thing where they're trying to layer in a
little bit of extra satisfaction with
the product so couple years ago BMW came
out with a car that when you press on
the accelerator it'll pipe extra engine
growl through the stereo in the in the
car so it's like more satisfying to step
on the gas um Ford just came up with
another one where they uh they the
engine noise is still there but they
have this valve that it'll only open and
let the engine noise into the car
interior um and past all the
soundproofing if you really slam on the
gas and like you know rev the RPMs up
but if you just drive like normal it'll
keep it soft and quiet um and so the uh
the point there is that all of those uh
products cars or chewing gum and many
others they find ways to layer immediate
satisfaction into the experience and
when you do that people want to repeat
it more anytime you have some kind of
enjoyment or a satisfying ending to a
behavior it's like this positive signal
in your brain that says hey that felt
good you should do this again next time
and that's what really gets a habit to
stick uh all the other stuff that we
talked about um making habits attractive
making them more obvious making it more
convenient to do that gets a habit to
start the first time or makes it easier
for you to do it right then but the only
reason you come back to it is because
it's satisfying and it's really about
the speed of the satisfaction and this
is something that I call the cardinal
rule of behavior change which is
behaviors that are immediately rewarded
get repeated and behaviors that are
immediately punished get avoided and the
more that you can have that positive
emotional feeling right away the more
reason you have to come back to a habit
in the future if you were coaching
someone who said I have no clue what I'm
supposed to do with my life I'm I'm lost
I have all these bad habits I smoke I
drink I eat donuts every day I have no
job um my room is
sloppy and I'm just
depressed what would you say to them to
get started with changing their life
around in the form of better habits well
you just need to pick one thing first of
all I think that uh I just mentioned a
few minutes ago um one of the most
powerful forms of motivation is progress
so seeing some progress I mean it could
be as simple as make your bed each day
right like but just doing that embodying
the identity of someone who's getting
better who's making progress just pick
one thing uh and use that
as this is true I mean Louis this is
something you've probably seen with a
lot of people that you've talked to but
habits are the foundation for Mastery so
if you you know say take a take a sport
like basketball um you need to be able
to dribble with both hands without
thinking before you can worry about what
strategy you're running on offense or
what kind of you know strategic play
you're going to run or what your
defensive scheme is or all this other
stuff right like you need to automate
the fundamentals of The Craft before you
can worry about the next level of
performance same thing is true for chess
you know like you need to know how the
chess pieces move automatically without
thinking about it before you can get
into all right what is myON going to do
and I'm going to do this and they're
going to do that and so I think this is
true not just at the peak levels of
performance that you integrate these
habits and used habits as the foundation
for the next level performance but also
true when you're getting started just
build one small thing carve out a 1%
change a 1% Improvement and use that as
a stepping stone to the next uh level
true Behavior change is really identity
change um because you're you're not
really looking to go from the type of
person who doesn't run to the type of
person who can run a 5k that's fine
that's good it's the outcome but the
goal is not to run a marathon the goal
is to become a runner the goal is not to
write a book the goal is to become a
writer and once you identify as that
type of person in a sense you're not
even really pursuing Behavior change
anymore you're just acting in alignment
with the type of person that you already
believe that you are you know it's like
one thing to say I want this it's
something different to say I am this one
of the most effective feelings one of
the most motivating States is the
feeling of progress yeah and if you're
focused on uh feeling guilty blaming
yourself for not improving feeling like
oh I'm not bu able to build better
habits because something's wrong with me
that's not a very uh productive state to
be in whereas if you shift it and say
all right the problem is not me the
problem is the system and if I'm going
to change the system then I can do X Y
and Z and we can talk about a variety of
those strategies but each time you do
that you take action and you build
progress and momentum and so I I think
it is a much more productive way to
approach the process of change because
it gives you something to actually work
on I mean all the rest of these
strategies a lot of the time it's about
stuff like you know think positive or
fake it till you make it or stuff like
that and there's nothing necessarily
wrong with that like certainly if you
want to think positive is sounds better
than thinking negatively um but my focus
is much more on practical action steps
how can we make the process of behavior
change actionable and give you something
that to do to design a system where
you're more likely to succeed and so I
think that's just a better place to
spend your time and
energy most people were familiar with
the story of the Good Samaritan stopping
along the side of the road to help uh
help a fallen person help someone in
need well Princeton their theology
school decided to run this uh experiment
and they brought in a bunch of theology
students they said all right we're all
familiar with the story of the Good
Samaritan we're going to break you up
into groups and you're going to go teach
in different rooms across campus you're
going to teach this story and so they
started talking about you know how they
were going to deliver the presentation
and so on they had a couple different
cohorts the one cohort they said all
right just go ahead and you know go off
and uh and deliver the presentation so
they went off to their rooms um the
second one though they did something
interesting they sent the group off but
on their way to the uh well they sent
the group off and they said by the way
we're running a little bit behind right
you you don't have very long to get
there it takes about 10 minutes you only
got five so we kind of need to hurry um
you're probably already going to be late
so they're in a rush they know they're
going to go give this presentation on
the way they planted an actor on the uh
on the campus and this actor is laying
on the ground hurt moaning in pain and
so they scream twice and then they cry
out and every single group went right
past the person in need to go give a
presentation about helping a person in
need right the one person even stepped
over the guy who was in pain in order to
get there now the point of this and what
I'd like to start talking about now is
the danger of being goal focused and
goal oriented these people had a goal
right to deliver a presentation and they
were so one-sided so narrow-minded so
focused on that goal that miss the
bigger picture in the perspective of
what they should have been doing in the
first place and I think that this can be
a danger of goals often and so instead I
would like to encourage us to focus on
systems systems rather than goals here
are some examples if you're a coach your
goal is to win a championship but your
system is what your team does at
practice each day if you're a writer
your goal might be to write a book maybe
even write a bestselling book but your
system is how you write each week the
schedule that you follow if you're an
entrepreneur your goal could be to build
a million-dollar business or 10 million
business but the system is the sales and
marketing process that you have the
systems are what actually make the
difference they're what Drive the
results and what I've seen having goals
is great having a vision having a dream
is nice it's important to know where
you're going and where you're headed
it's important to have some clarity of
focus to know that we're moving in this
direction but once you know that having
the go on paper makes very little
difference and committing to the system
and showing up every day drives a lot of
results having a coach forces you to be
aware of things that you would otherwise
Overlook right like as you this is what
I call the downside of building good
habits which is you build habits and in
the beginning you develop fluency and
skill and ability and Things become
easier but after a little while once a
habit has been established the downside
of having a habit is that you can do it
good enough on autopilot which means
that you start to overlook your mistakes
and not think about how to get better
and so what you need is a coach to keep
you on that Razor's Edge so that you you
keep building habits but it also for
forces you to stay aware of what the
next level of performance is and that's
kind of the challenge of continuous
Improvement it's like a cycle you know
it starts with awareness if you're not
aware of what your habits are or what
your behavior is you don't have a chance
to change it then from that awareness
you go to deliberate practice where you
have to effortfully try and work to get
better and eventually the thing that you
were deliberately practicing becomes a
habit and becomes automatic but once it
becomes automatic that's not the end you
have to return to awareness and see
where you're at now start the cycle
again basically there are these little
moments throughout the day well if you
depending on what research study you
look at habits account for 40 to 50% of
our daily behaviors and this is all the
stuff that you're just doing without
even thinking you know tying your shoes
or unplugging the toaster after each
time you use it or whatever um but the
true influence of your habits is even
greater than that because in many ways
habits are kind of like a fork in the
road they're like a an entrance ramp on
the highway so you do something
mindlessly like you pull your phone out
of your pocket and you don't even think
about it takes 5 Seconds but after you
do that it shapes the next like 20
minutes of conscious attention and
choices that you're making so maybe you
browse social media or you respond to
email or you play a video game but
whatever Choice you're making it was
already uh the context was already
shaped by that mindless habit of pulling
your phone out and so I would refer to
that as like a decisive moment they
these little automatic actions that you
do them and then after 30 seconds
they've already shaped the next 20
minutes or the next chunk of time that's
going to come there are a couple ways to
think about it but I would say just
quick definition a habit is a behavior
that has been repeated enough times to
be performed more or less automatically
uh so you can do it pretty much on
autopilot but another way to think about
it I think this is a useful way to
define a habit is that as you go through
life you face different problems and
some of those problems are big and some
of them are small like you need to tie
your shoes and whenever you face a
problem your brain starts looking for
solutions to that and as you come across
Solutions to the recurring problems in
life you start to automate those and so
every morning you wake up and you put
your shoes on and you got this little
problem that you need to solve and
pretty soon after you tie your shoes 100
times or 500 times or thousand times you
can do it pretty much without thinking
and so that's another way of thinking
about habits is that they're kind of
these like automatic Solutions we fall
into for whatever the recurring problems
are we face right behavior that becomes
habituated yeah and you know like there
the interesting thing about this is you
don't necess neily have to have the same
Habit to solve a recurring problem like
if you come home from work each day and
you feel stressed and exhausted one
person might uh play video games for an
hour and that's a way to resolve that
problem so they get in the habit of
doing it and they just walk over the
controller they don't think about it
another person might go for a run for 20
minutes or meditate for 10 minutes third
person might smoke a cigarette and all
of those are just solutions to that
problem that you're facing and uh that I
think is another powerful lesson is is
that your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal one and once you
realize that then it kind of becomes
your responsibility to become a little
more aware of what those habits are and
then think about Can you shape them or
design them and right how much willpower
do we have
so you hear this a lot I mean it's very
common especially in self-help
motivation self-improvement you need to
be motivated you have to have willpower
grit and perseverance are huge and
important and it's not that those
qualities are not important it's just
that the way to develop them is
different than what most people think so
most people think I need willpower so I
should just try harder there's an
interesting body of research I mentioned
it in the book I think it's in chapter 7
on self-control and willpower which is
that the people who appear to have the
greatest self-control actually are just
tempted the least so they face
Temptations less frequently and
therefore have the Reserves and the
resources to resist it when it
occasionally comes up and I think that
this is actually like the lever to pull
or the pressure point to push on is that
the way to get better willpower is to
design an environment that tempts you
less not to say let me just try harder
what is the best first step you found
when you share this with people with
leaders to make better decisions to
start those habits what's the thing
that's the stickiest where people go oh
my gosh yes I can do that if you just
want something really tactical just's a
very specific way to Kickstart a habit I
like to recommend the two-minute rule so
it's very simple it just says take what
ever habit you're trying to build and
scale it down to something that takes 2
minutes or less to do so read 30 books a
year becomes read one page or do yoga
four days a week becomes take out my
yoga mat and sometimes people resist
this a little bit you know they're like
okay buddy you know I know the real goal
isn't just to take my yoga mat out I
know I'm actually trying to do the
workout you know so this is some kind of
mental trick and I know it's a trick
then why would I fall for it basically
and I get where people are coming from
but I have this reader his name is Mitch
I mentioned him in atomic habits and uh
he lost over 100 lb he's kept it off for
more than a decade but when he first
started going to the gym he had this
strange little rule for himself where he
wouldn't stay for longer than 5 minutes
so he get in the car drive to the gym
get out do half an exercise get back in
the car drive home and it sounds
ridiculous you know it sounds silly
you're like clearly this is not going to
work for the guy but if you take a step
back what you realize is he was
mastering the art of showing up you know
he was becoming the typ of person that
went to the gymm 4 days a week even if
it was only for 5 minutes and I think
that's a deep truth about habits you
know it's something people often
Overlook which is a habit must be
established before it can be improved
you know it has to become the standard
in your life or in your business before
you can scale it up and optimize it and
turn it into something more standardize
before you optimize and so I think that
the two minute rule kind of pushes back
on that perfectionist tendency just
execute a little bit you know execute in
a small way get some proof get some
evidence become the type of person or
the type of business that does this
consistently even if it's smaller than
what you ultimately hope to do and then
from that new uh from that like new
foothold that you've established you can
advance and optimize and improve from
there once you're showing up there are
almost endless opportunities for
improvement but you can have the best
plan possible and if you can't get
yourself to show up consistently it
doesn't really matter so the two-minute
rule is perhaps a good place to start
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Andrew huberman motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there and the reward
system you start to realize is entirely
internal no one's coming along and
cramming dopamine in your ear or
dripping it in your brain it's all
internal and this starts to bring us
into the kind of like discussion around
mindsets